the final step in your custom view
creation is adding interactivity you can
listen for user input events including
key presses track ball movement and most
importantly screen touch events all by
overriding the corresponding event
handles android supports tracking of up
to 11 individual contact points in what
we like to call jazz hands mode which
enables you to complete complex
multi-finger interaction models now
there's really no interaction required
for a wind gauge but you can find out
more about handling input events by
checking the emotion event docks or the
developer guide describing how to create
your own fully interactive custom views
both from the instructor notes below now
be careful not to let this newfound
power go to your head by definition your
users will have never encountered your
brand spanking new control so learning
how to use it is going to add friction
to their use of your app at the very
least it should behave consistently with
the rest of the system and you should
avoid creating your own versions of
system controls if it looks kind of like
a button and works kind of like a button
you should probably just go ahead and
use a button but i think this non
sequitur has gone on long enough